New Microsoft AI agent destroys
OpenClaw. Microsoft just dropped a brand
new AI agent. It does not just talk. It
actually does the work for you. And
honestly, it might just crush OpenClaw.
Today, I am going to show you everything
it can do, how it works, and why this
changes the game for everyone. Uh, stick
around because this one is big. So,
here's what just happened. Microsoft
came out with something called Copilot
Tasks. And look, we have all used AI
chatbots before. You ask a question, you
get an answer. Cool. But that is where
it stops. You still have to do the
actual work yourself. Copilot tasks is
different. This thing does not just give
you answers. It goes out and does the
thing like it will schedule your
meetings. It will write your documents.
It will organize your entire week all
from one simple instruction. You give it
in plain English. Think about that for a
second. You type in something like plan
my week and set up all my meetings and
it actually goes and does it. It opens
your calendar. It books the slots. It
drafts the emails. It builds the agenda.
You did not lift a finger. That is what
we are talking about here. Now, let me
break down exactly how this works
because it is kind of wild. Step one,
you give it a goal. Just tell it what
you want in normal words. Nothing fancy.
Step two, Copilot breaks that goal into
smaller steps like a little plan. It
builds for itself. Step three, and this
is the crazy part, it uses its own
computer in the cloud, its own browser,
its own setup. It does not touch your
device. it goes off and does the work on
its own machine. Step four, if it is
about to do something big like send an
email or make a change, it asks you
first. So, you are still in control. And
step five, when it is done, it gives you
a full report of everything it did. That
is the whole flow. Goal, plan, execute,
check-in, report. Done. Hey, if we have
not met already, I am the digital avatar
of Julian Goldie, CEO of Goldie Agency.
While he is helping clients get more
leads and customers, I am here to help
you get the latest AI updates. Julian
Goldie reads every single comment, so
make sure you drop one below. Seriously,
he reads them all. All right, so let me
give you some real examples of what
people are already doing with co-pilot
tasks. First one, email management. You
know how your inbox is a disaster?
Copilot tasks can go through it,
unsubscribe from junk, draft replies,
and sort everything. Second, scheduling.
It can book meetings, set up
appointments, even look at flights for
you. Third, content creation. You can
tell it to turn an email chain into a
full presentation or create a report
from scratch. It pulls the info, builds
the slides, formats everything. Fourth,
monitoring. You can set it to watch for
things or new job listings or changes on
a website, and it will come back and
tell you when something happens. Fifth,
study plans and agendas. Students and
professionals can use it to build out
full weekly plans with zero effort. Now,
here's where it gets really interesting.
Let me talk about how this stacks up
against OpenClaw because that is the big
question, right? Microsoft is not being
shy about it either. Their CEO said
Copilot Tasks talks less and does more.
That is a direct shot at every other AI
assistant out there. So, what makes
Copilot Task different from OpenClaw? A
few things. Number one, Microsoft
integration. Copilot tasks plugs
straight into Outlook, Word, Excel,
PowerPoint, Calendar, and the browser.
That is huge. If you are already using
Microsoft tools, this thing just slides
right in. Open Claw does not have that.
Number two, the consent system. Copilot
Tasks asks you before it does anything
major. It is not just running wild. You
approve the big moves. That gives you
safety and control. Number three, cloud
execution. It runs everything on its own
cloud computer. So, your device is free.
your battery is fine, your laptop is not
melting, is all happening somewhere
else. Now, if you are watching this and
thinking, "Wow, I want to use AI like
this to actually grow my business and
save time," then you need to check out
the AI profit boardroom. It is the best
place to scale your business, get more
customers, and save hundreds of hours
with AI automation. If you want to learn
how to use tools like C-pilot Tasks to
automate your workflows, and get ahead
of everyone else, that is exactly what
we cover in there. Link is in the
description. Go check it out. All right,
back to the breakdown. Let me talk about
what is not perfect yet because I always
keep it real with you. First, Copilot
Tasks is in a limited research preview
right now. That means not everyone can
use it yet. There is a wait list. You
can sign up and get in line, but it is
not open to the public fully. Second,
some actions still need your approval
before they go through, which is
actually a good thing for safety, but it
does mean it is not fully hands-off yet.
Third, we do not know the full scope of
what it can and cannot do outside of the
Microsoft ecosystem. Like, can it work
with tools that are not Microsoft? That
is still a bit unclear. But here is the
thing. Even with those limits, this is a
massive step forward. We are moving from
AI that answers questions to AI that
completes tasks. That is a totally
different level. Think about where we
were a year ago. We were excited about
AI writing a paragraph for us. Now we
have AI that schedules our whole week,
builds presentations, manages our inbox,
and monitors the internet for us. The
speed of this is insane. And this is not
just for tech people. This is for
everyone. And if you run a business,
this can handle your admin. If you are a
student, this can organize your study
schedule. If you are a freelancer, this
can draft proposals and manage your
calendar. The use cases are endless. Let
me also point out something important.
Microsoft is playing the long game here.
They are not just building a chatbot.
They are building an AI workforce.
C-pilot tasks is one piece of a much
bigger picture. They want AI that is
woven into every part of how you work.
And with their reach with Windows, with
Office, with Teams, with Outlook, they
have the infrastructure to actually pull
it off. That is something most
competitors just do not have. Now, I
know some of you are thinking, is this
safe? And that is a fair question. The
consent system is key here. Copilot
Tasks does not just go rogue. It checks
in with you before making big moves. It
shows you the plan before it executes
and it gives you a full report after so
you always know what happened. That is
smart design because trust is everything
with AI tools. If people do not trust
it, they will not use it. Microsoft
clearly thought about that. Let me also
give you a pro tip. When this opens up
to more people, and it will, the ones
who learn it first will have the biggest
advantage. That is how it always works
with new tech. The early adopters win.
So get on that weight list now. Start
learning how it works. Watch what other
people are doing with it and be ready to
hit the ground running when you get
access. So to wrap this up, Copilot
Tasks is Microsoft's answer to OpenClaw.
It is an agentic AI that does not just
chat with you. It plans, it executes,
and it reports back. It works across
Outlook, Calendar, Word, Excel,
PowerPoint, and browsers. It runs on its
own cloud computer so your device stays
free. It asks before doing anything
major. and it is in preview right now
with a wait list open. This is the
future of AI, not just talking, doing,
and Microsoft is betting everything on
it. Now, if you want to stay ahead of
all of this, if you want to use AI tools
like copilot tasks to automate your
workflows, grow your business, and save
hundreds of hours, join the AI profit
boardroom. We break down every major AI
tool, show you exactly how to use them,
and help you build systems that run on
autopilot. The link is in the
description. Do not sleep on this. And
if you want the full process, SOPs and
over a 100 AI use cases like this one,
join the AI success lab. Links in the
comments and description. You'll get all
the video notes from there, plus access
to our community of 38,000 members who
are crushing it with AI. It is
completely free to join. Inside the
community, you will find breakdowns of
every major AI tool that drops,
step-by-step walkthroughs on how to
actually use them, and templates you can
copy and paste into your own workflow.
New automations, new workflows, new ways
to use AI that most people have not even
heard of yet. And you get direct access
to all of it. So, go join now. It is
free. There is literally no reason not
to. Link is in the comments and the
description. Julian Goldie reads every
comment, so drop a comment below and let
him know what you think about Copilot
Tasks. Are you going to try it? Do you
think it beats Open Claw? Let us know.
And smash that subscribe button so you
never miss an update. I will see you in
the next